there are two things that surprised me
about using the surface go to one almost
made me throw it out and another makes
this machine absolutely amazing for a
small group of people I'll explain in
just a bit I'm reviewing the four
hundred dollar model whereas most
reviewers were sent the six hundred and
thirty dollar one as twice the RAM and
storage it is also faster but I wanted
to go with the base since I think that
most people will be really attracted to
the go-to because of that price point of
course that is just the tablet by itself
so add on another hundred dollars for
the cheaper keyboard and another hundred
for the surface pen and it's no longer
as inexpensive as it seems the tablet
itself is built mostly out of aluminum
and it feels really nice especially for
the price the kickstand is built super
well and it works great Microsoft has
been doing a killer job with our kick
stands and this thing works really well
with a lot of adjustability I love that
we have a built in a micro SD card
reader for only about fifty bucks you
can more than quadruple the base storage
although I didn't leave a link to my
recommended cheap and fast micro SD card
in the description below as far as ports
we have a headphone jack a USB type-c
port at full 10 gigabit per second
speeds which is awesome in the surface
connect port that is used for charging
with the included 24 watt fast charger
or for using Microsoft's pricey
proprietary accessories like the new
travel hub or the surface dock to which
a link to down below on the front we
have a 10 and a half inch screen that's
decent it's not a sharp or bright as
Apple's cheapest iPad at about 350 myths
which means it is prone to reflections
in bright rooms and outdoors one thing I
definitely have to complain about are
the speakers I was excited for the dual
front-facing speakers but they are so
quiet I went through all the settings
and they can't even compete with current
smartphones or the cheapest iPad that
only has bottom firing speakers take a
listen for yourselves
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
another issue I found was the windows
hello facial authentication
I love laptops that include this and I'm
glad to see that the go-to does as well
but it is really finicky and lower light
conditions about half the time in you
know the evening with lights turned out
in my room it just won't work and I have
to use the pin the surface laptop Reed
doesn't have this issue so I really hope
that it's just software and it can be
improved one of the selling points is
being able to write and draw on the
display and it works okay I say that
because just like the display even the
cheapest iPad does a much better job
with drawing because as much less lag
and the app selection is so much greater
now if you're somebody that does a lot
of typing the experience is surprisingly
good Microsoft was one of the first to
make keyboard covers with trackpads and
though it's not the best the cover we
bought was only $99 so for the price it
is fantastic because the cover didn't
change you can even pick it up for
cheaper which I'll link to below the
keys are a bit small but that's fairly
common at this size and you do get used
to them and after a day or two the keys
themselves have decent travel and feel
good before we get into why I almost
threw it out let's talk about the most
shocking thing I found while using it
and that is the webcam I don't know how
Microsoft managed to put in such a high
quality 1080p webcam and great
microphones into a $400 tablet
Apple's most expensive MacBook Pro
webcam is 720p and the quality of the
image is blown away by the go to the
post-processing and colors are good we
have a nice detailed image with very
little noise and on top of that there
are two front-facing microphones that
pick up voices very well Bravo Microsoft
and Apple please take notes battery life
is quite poor though I got four to five
hours for basic mixed use but thankfully
it charges in just over an hour with
included charger
and standby time was also good and now
for the biggest downside the performance
now sure I know I have the base model
but that was on purpose out of the box
it ships in balance power mode but that
is way too slow so I had to keep it in
the maximum performance mode to even be
usable it also comes in Windows s mode
but in order to use most apps even basic
ones like zoom you'll have to change to
regular windows which thankfully is easy
and free once windows is loaded the
performance is sluggish but usable
opening up Adobe's more optimized mobile
version of Lightroom from the Microsoft
Store took over 20 seconds compared to
two seconds on the iPad now I keep
comparing it to the iPad since even
though they're using different operating
systems they're both in the same price
point and have a similar audience the
actual editing experience was very slow
even with small JPEG files so bra
editing is a no-go many other apps are
also slow for me so I think that the
base go-to is really only usable with
simple web tasks with only a few tabs
open the performance was noticeably
slower than a basic iPad or laptop with
things taking longer to load even though
it has fast Wi-Fi 6 I ran a web browser
benchmark and the results explained why
it felt so slow it scored 3 times slower
than the slowest iPad and that is in the
best performance mode now with some
patience it could still be usable unless
Windows is running some background tasks
I was in YouTube studio and my blood
basically started to boil because the
ghosts slowed down so much that it took
20 seconds or more to open a web page
and at times it even failed to open I
had left my laptop at the office as I
typically do in reviewing new devices so
I had no choice but to use it and it
took me 15 minutes to do what I normally
can do in 5 minutes or less and by the
end of that I was just so tempted to
throw it out the window that was open
next to me not only does the base model
have shockingly low performance scores
being smoked by the cheapest iPad which
by itself uses an old CPU from 2016
but adding on full-fledged windows
really puts a huge toll on it as soon as
you have a few apps open or more than
just a few tabs or as in my case just
having some background tasks open that I
wasn't able to control it just slows the
whole thing down to a crawl now there is
a core m3 option to speed things up but
there are two issues first that costs an
extra two hundred and thirty dollars and
then adding the keyboard and possibly a
pen makes it a much more expensive
purchase the second is that even with
the best CPU option it is barely faster
than the four-year-old a10 and it
doesn't have the luxury of having a well
optimized OS so it will still be a slow
machine and have poor performance for
the money my biggest issue with the
go-to is I feel like Microsoft shouldn't
be selling the base model I understand
wanting to hit that low price point
which will sell well but shipping it
with the processor that is basically
unusable at times is super frustrating
this would have been a much more
compelling device if they kept the base
storage and RAM but use the m3 processor
even if that meant having a slightly
higher price point I still think that
the go-to could be a fantastic machine
for those that value portability and
mostly do a lot of web conferencing and
also a decent machine if you want to do
basic tasks and occasionally require a
machine that has Windows but I would
really strongly compel anyone that is
considering it to spend that extra $230
for the core m3 model even though that
is a really high price to pay
just to have usable consistent
performance thank you guys for watching
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below of course we do
have links to the go to the accessories
and some great prices for the keyboards
down in the video description you guys
can click that circle above to subscribe
if you guys want to see more videos and
if you want to see a comparison to the
basic iPad with a keyboard case with the
trackpad click right over there
there's been max and I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]